[Música]
olá eu tô feliz demais destaque hoje
gente eu precisava vencer algumas coisas
que para muitas pessoas pode parecer
insignificante
bom meu nome é daniel balaban boato
hoje eu estudo geografia na universidade
federal de uberlândia e mais ou menos
uns três anos que eu me contento
atlético
ela considera um rapaz muito vencedor
não sei se já falaram pra vocês sabem
não apresentou mas eu sou muito curioso
também e eu gostaria de saber de vocês
quais são as suas vitórias
quais são as vitórias que vocês acham
que realmente vão importar quando você
estiver em 50 anos
e dessas vitórias quais vocês acham que
vão atingir de uma forma positiva vida
das pessoas à sua volta
desde pequeno eu sempre fui muito
brincalhão e muito bagunceiro
eu me lembro que na primeira série os
meus professores descobriram que eu
aprendi algumas matérias mais rápido que
os outros alunos
então vai conseguir conter a euforia as
minhas brincadeiras
eles me ensinaram ajudar meus amigos
desvendar em algumas fórmulas bem
complicadas de matemática na época eu
ajudava eles a somam mais um ou diminuir
3 - 2
pode parecer pouco né mas naquela época
eu já me sentia vencedor
eu não sabia ainda mas ajudar as pessoas
e isso é uma coisa importante pra mim
foi assim mas até 8ª séria e quando fiz
15 anos os meus pais se separaram que eu
me vi obrigado a começar a trabalhar
então eu arrumei um estágio no banco e
lá também existem algumas funções bem
difíceis eu
ajudava as pessoas mexem nos caixas
eletrônicos também pode parecer pouco né
mas para algumas pessoas isso realmente
é difícil e também por perceber isso
naquela época eu também considerava isso
uma vitória é bom com a pouca
independência financeira que eu tive eu
consegui começar a viajar e e eu
realizei um dos meus maiores sonhos que
foi conhecer o estádio do meu time de
futebol
eu conheci também o estádio do maracanã
que é um símbolo do futebol mundial e já
quando eu comecei a freqüentar os
estádios eu fui privilegiado e conhecer
uma das melhores sensações que eu tive
até hoje eu ganhei um abraço de uma
pessoa desconhecida a gente eu ganhei um
abraço de uma pessoa que nunca tinha
visto na minha vida e é engraçado para
pensar aqui hoje aqui em cima da cadeira
de rodas
isso ficou muito mais freqüente na minha
vida é por várias vezes eu abraço de
alguém porque a pessoa se inspirou na
minha história ou porque a minha
superação tá conseguindo ajudar pessoas
de uma forma positiva
sim essa vitória também está
influenciando de uma forma boa vida das
pessoas
mas para você entender um pouco melhor
foi mais ou menos assim até os 24 anos
eu sempre trabalhei com vendas e com um
atendimento ao cliente e por mais que as
pessoas sempre me procuravam com algum
tipo de problema ou em alguma situação
meio desagradável porque esse jeitão
assim meio brincalhão eu conseguir
contornar a situação e em muitos dos
casos eu consegui conquistar a confiança
das pessoas
em alguns casos eu conseguir também
conquistar o coração dessas pessoas eu
falo isso porque hoje várias delas estão
presentes na minha vida e hoje eu tenho
certeza que todas as pessoas que estão à
minha volta fazem questão de stan tem
uma mulher que ficou um pouco mais
conhecida mundialmente ela chama
michelle obama foi a primeira mulher
negra
a ser primeira dama de um presidente
negro dos estados unidos
ela nos deixou uma frase que eu
considero um privilégio
o sucesso não tem a ver com o dinheiro
que a gente vai ganhar
o sucesso tem a ver com a diferença que
a gente vai fazer na vida das pessoas
e cá entre nós fazer a diferença pra mim
sempre foi um tipo de sucesso
bom como eu comecei a trabalhar muito
cedo eu perdi o interesse pelos estudos
mas eu visse os meus amigos tentando
passar no vestibular ou se preparando ou
simplesmente entrando na faculdade da
minha realidade não era possível eu não
tinha como eu precisava realmente ajudar
dentro da minha casa mas eu sempre achei
que com um pouco mais de conhecimento
com um é um pouco mais de portas abertas
por causa da faculdade e atingir uma
forma positiva a vida das pessoas
e aí eu me inscrevi no vestibular e
comecei a escolher o meu curso
o que mais me chamou a atenção foi o
curso de geografia
ele envolve alguns aspectos sociais
alguns aspectos ambientais e
tecnológicos também que me desperta uma
curiosidade bem gostosa de estudar e
como eu disse para vocês eu achava que
isso seria muito mais portas da minha
vida
assim como também não agora mas falando
voltando ao futebol foi meu pai quem me
apresentou
ele me levou no estádio do meu time de
coração e quando cheguei lá eu fiquei
maravilhado com a torcida realmente
parecia uma festa
sei que todo mundo ali se conhecia e
eles iam sempre em prol do mesmo
objetivo
hoje eu uso o futebol em muitas
situações a minha vida para me inspirar
ou para me espelhar em várias vezes o
time ganha várias vezes o time perde
algumas vezes o time precisa muito do
esforço do time todo para conseguir uma
vitória e praticamente todas as vezes
uma partida decidida nos detalhes e
a minha vida também se tornou assim
quando eu passei na faculdade e mudei
para a cidade que eu ia começar a
faculdade eu tive essa mesma sensação
a sensação de um gol sabe quando o
brasil ganhou a copa do mundo ou quando
o brasil faz um gol ea gente sai pulando
na sala tipo de sangue é brasileira bem
roque júnior o xeque a cabeça na bola e
faz o corte
cafu domina aí aparece o kleberson de
novo já partiu pela direita
cafu já partiu em velocidade ele foi o
primeiro a ver o crédito privado saio
promenade de direito bateu
[Aplausos]
aqui no brasil
o gol
o
[Aplausos]
essa mesma sensação ficou muito mais
recorrente na via quando eu passei na
faculdade também eu não conhecia muitas
pessoas mas eu quando passei na
faculdade passei a ganhar um pouco mais
de abraço das pessoas que eu ainda não
conhecia
simplesmente porque eles também se
identificavam com a minha vitória
vocês lembram quando eu falo sobre as
minhas vitórias envolvem a vida de
outras pessoas de uma forma bem legal eu
considero isso como um tipo de sucesso
também mas eu não sei se vocês sabem
porém muita gente já sabe disso
o futebol ele é uma caixinha de surpresa
e o que a gente ainda não sabe é que a
nossa vida também pode ser uma caixinha
de surpresa
depois que eu fazia na faculdade eu tive
uma das minhas piores derrotas foi
praticamente como 7 a 1 do brasil aqui
na copa do brasil
eu realmente não esperava passar por
aquilo e eu também não me preparei pra
aquilo é bom quando eu passei a morar há
entulho estava eu comecei uma república
ea gente fazia você estivesse conectada
com muita gente e isso me lembra também
aquela torcida que apoiava o time nos
campos de futebol mas em um dia como se
fosse uma final
é uma festa um pouco maior em uma
chácara bem grande
eu lembro praticamente de todos os
detalhes
tinha bastante gente lembra de brincar
com as pessoas que eu já conhecia mas
depois quando estava quase acabando a
festa praticamente nos acréscimos da
partida eu cometi o maior gol contra
eu decidi ir lá na piscina quando eu
pulei eu apaguei
olhei o cenário é bem diferente
eu já estava fora da piscina tinha
bastante gente na minha volta mas eu não
entendia praticamente nada eles me
perguntavam se eu estava bem o que
estava acontecendo mas eu já era
praticamente não conseguia mexer meu
corpo e eu já não conseguia mais falar
a princípio meus amigos acharam que
estava brincando também mas eles
perceberam que eu não demonstrava reação
eles entenderam que era sério ea partir
daí o cenário foi muito diferente de
algumas lâmpadas de ambulância
eu lembro de ver o meu corpo deitado
numa maca me lembro vagamente do
hospital
mas aí eu apaguei de novo lembra de mais
alguns flashes e foi assim por uma
semana uma semana em coma
quando eu acordei o cenário é bem
diferente
estava um quarto todo branco com as
luzes bem fortes praticamente que vai
ver que está aqui mas mesmo sem entender
nada
eu recebi uma das notícias que mais
marcou depois desse dia
eu gostaria de saber de vocês quando foi
a última vez que alguma pessoa falar pra
vocês que vocês não podem mais fazer
alguma coisa quando foi também falei pra
vocês que vocês não poderíamos sentar
comer falar ou até mesmo andar sozinho
poderiam ser coisas insignificantes né
mas a partir desse momento eu entendi o
poder de um não mas mesmo assim como o
jeito brincalhão e com meus pais e meu
irmão do lado eu vim para os médicos
quando recebi essa notícia falei gente
vocês não conhecem o danilinho ainda eu
tenho certeza que eu vou ficar muito bem
eu virei pro meu irmão pediu meu celular
e quando ele me deu eu não consegui
segurar esse aí foi meu primeiro contato
até a poesia bom
depois desse dia
algumas vitórias eu passei a sair do
respirador
eu não precisava de aparelhos para
respirar eu tirei uma sonda que foi
produzido até um estômago pelo poder
comer e a partir daí eu fui o quarto
já no quarto uma das minhas maiores
vitórias foi quando eu conseguir fechar
um procedimento que foi feito na minha
garganta chamado traqueostomia para
vocês entenderem basicamente é um cano
enfiada na nossa garganta a gente poder
respirar aquilo me deixava falar eu
estava imóvel eu praticamente não
conseguia demonstrar expressões e não
falar me irritar bastante mas não
conseguiu fechar até autonomia
eu me lembro que minha mãe estava do
lado e as únicas duas palavras que eu
consegui falar bem baixinho foi oi mãe
eu repetir aquela palavra mais umas dez
vezes pelo menos
oi mãe oi mãe que aquilo era como se
fosse um canto de torcida também
mas a única pessoa que estava do meu
lado naquele momento era minha mãe
também beleza
depois essas pequenas vitórias já no
quarto por conhecerem esse meu jeito
brincalhão
os enfermeiros brincavam com a expansão
sempre quando eles iam me dar banho na
cama e brincavam mas um dos enfermeiros
me chamam muita atenção e ele sempre
brincava com a mesma fisionomia e toda
vez que ele entrava falar aberta
não quero mais isso não aguento mais
isso por favor chega vamos tentar do
jeito que ele fala pra mim danilo calma
acabando
só falta 400 e praticamente todos os
dias e repetir a mesma coisa
ele entrava no quarto eu falava que não
queria mais ele fala danilo aproveita
que está acabando
só faltam 400
os dias foram passando e no dia recebi a
alta ele entrou no quarto para se
despedir de mim e eu perguntei pra ele
beto que aquela história
pra mim foi o daniel aqui nos arredores
do hospital passa um carro com o rapaz
veneno para amanhã
e toda vez que ele passa em volta do
hospital ele fala olha o carro da
pamonha aproveitem que está acabando
só faltam 400 para que na hora entende
na hora fiquei revoltado mas ele sim ele
simplesmente quis dizer que ainda
faltavam algumas coisas para a gente
aproveitar enquanto ainda faltava
hoje eu tenho certeza que aqui com vocês
é uma das formas de aproveitar as
pamonhas que ainda tenho seis lojas as
vitórias que eu venho conquistando com
certeza tem influência de uma forma
positiva as pessoas que estão à minha
volta mas tudo bem
quando fui para minha casa o cenário
também continua parecido mas que estava
dentro do meu quarto dentro do meu
habitat natural eu estava numa cama de
hospital eu não conseguia me mexer ainda
e ao mesmo tempo precisava sentar
sozinho aprender a sentar sozinho eu
também precisava aprender a sair de casa
saí de casa
[Música]
hum hum hum hum
ae o autor vai embora
olha aí sim depois desse dia eu bem a
oportunidade e me internar em um
hospital de ressocialização pessoas com
lesões medulares
lá eles me apresentaram algumas coisas
que mel se amy auxiliariam até um pouco
mais de liberdade nessa nova vida vai me
apresentar algumas órteses algumas
próteses algumas adaptações que eu
poderia usar mas o que eu mais gostei
foi a cadeira de rodas
quando cheguei lá eles me apresentaram
uma cadeira que dirigia simplesmente com
o queijo era o único movimento que eu
tinha e já no primeiro dia eu fiz aí
bom foi incrível isso pra mim a sensação
que eu tive realmente foi parecida com
go
aquele evento batendo no meu rosto
realmente me fez pareceu airton sena
é lógico que não do mesmo jeito mas sim
foi essencialmente a liberdade que eu
senti e em outro rapaz muito conhecida
mundialmente também chamado steven
hawking
depois de ser diagnosticado com a doença
regenerativa ele nos deixou uma frase
que realmente faz muita parte da minha
vida hoje
ele disse pra gente que apesar que ele
precisar de uma cadeira de rodas ou de
alguns aparelhos para conseguir se
comunicar dentro da cabeça dele ele era
livre e é assim que me sinto hoje bom
liberdade do dicionário tem algumas
extensões
mas as palavras que vai me chamar a
atenção para compartilhar com vocês são
a autonomia independência e soberania
quando eu perdi minha autonomia eu não
conseguia mais escovar os dentes ou
lavar o rosto
isso me deixou muito mais deprimido eu
fui desistindo de algumas coisas quando
eu perdi a minha independência eu parei
de sair na rua eu não via mais os
pedestres
eu não via mais os bairros as baladas
que eu costumava freqüentar
e nem os carros do trânsito eu via isso
foi criando uma dependência muito grande
e que depois de um tempo passando eu fui
deixando de fazer as coisas e por vários
dias nenhum só eu vim porque eu não
deixava minha janela do meu quarto
foi quando eu entrei no ponto ápice da
minha independência com os poucos
movimentos que eu tinha eu pulei da cama
e gente de verdade eu só queria fugir
daquele problema mas a única coisa que
eu consegui mudar com essa atitude foi
de um galo na cabeça bem dolorido de
verdade
bom quando eu retomei a minha sabedoria
eu entendi que a gente pode fazer
escolhas
foi quando eu escolher participar da
oportunidade de estar aqui hoje
nesse período do meu tratamento a única
coisa que eu não parei de fazer foi a
fisioterapia durante um dos treinos eu
consegui ficar equilibrado na minha cama
sem nenhum custo
eu postei essa foto da minha rede social
quando eu postei essa foto um dos
organizadores do ted me mandou uma
mensagem falando que eu tinha uma idéia
para compartilhar com vocês mas eu não
acreditava nisso há vários dias eu não
acreditava que esses tipos de vitórias
também mereciam ser compartilhados mas
os dias foram passando e com essa
oportunidade eu tive a oportunidade de
voltar a comer de voltar a sair na rua
da minha casa
voltar ver gente e hoje está aqui
essa pequena vitória também é como
ganhar uma partida de futebol pra mim e
pra finalizar eu queria contar uma coisa
pra vocês
quando o meu time de coração foi
disputar a final do campeonato mundial
torneio de imprensa dizia que nós não
conseguimos conseguirmos ser campeões
que nós éramos os azarões nós éramos a
zebra do campeonato mas em uma das
entrevistas o técnico do meu time disse
que se a gente ia ganhar ou não isso ele
não sabia mas que a nossa cara a gente
ia mostrar
é claro que hoje eu utilizei o futebol
para me inspirar e vai deixar essa
história um pouco mais é pra vocês
conseguirem entender mas eu vim aqui
hoje simplesmente para mostrar minha
cara quer dizer pra vocês que você
também precisa mostrar a cara de vocês
mostrem a cara de vocês também vão atrás
da vitória de vocês por mais distante
que parece estar só depende de vocês vêm
são seus próprios medos com certeza vai
valer a pena
muito obrigado